Batman is often treated like a God among
mortal superheroes by dedicated comic
fans after all he's basically a genius
ninja detective billionaire with enough
money to build weapons designed to beat
the most powerful heroes and villains in
the DC Universe still comics writers
like to remind readers that Batman is
totally capable of having his bat butt
kicked up and down the streets of Gotham
even though he always bounces back let's
take a look at some of the heroes and
villains that have destroyed Batman Bane
let's start with the obvious one the big
bad guy that beat Batman so badly it
made the evening news in the summer of
1993 DC kicked off a major Batman event
called nightfall in which Batman become
burnt out after Bane releases all of his
greatest villains from Arkham Asylum at
once while past his overworked and
overstressed Bane discovers that the
Dark Knight is Bruce Wayne which leads
to a violent showdown in the Batcave
things don't go well for Batman Bane
dominates the fight against a weakened
cake crusader he lifts Batman over his
head and brings him crashing down over
his knee breaking Batman's back and
putting him completely out of commission
it's become such an iconic takedown that
it made its way to the big screen in the
Dark Knight Rises Oh
it really is the most devastating hit
that Batman has ever taken but it's not
the only one Superman even within the
ridiculous medium of comics where
anything is possible it takes a lot to
believe Batman has a realistic shot at
you feeding Superman in a one-on-one
fight but somehow Batman often seems to
come out on top
often but not always there was the time
villain Maxwell Lord made Superman
hallucinate that he was battling
Darkseid in the gladiatorial arena when
in reality he was beating on Batman so
badly that Bruce ended up in a coma in
the story Lex Luthor Man of Steel
Batman is planning to attack Superman
with kryptonite only to have Supes
literally blow the rock out of that
man's hand then pound Batman who within
an inch of his life
again or how about the time an alien
parasite called Black Rock took over
Batman's body granting him superhuman
strength slight and a whole lot of crazy
even fighting a Batman with superpowers
Superman was able to punch the parasite
right out of his body by the way
punching is typically not a good
solution for dealing with parasites
Wonder Woman in the 2016 graphic novel
Wonder Woman the hikky taya Batman is on
the hunt for a woman responsible for the
deaths of sex slavers and drug dealers
in Gotham and she just so happens to be
the very same person Wonder Woman has
been honorbound to protect when the two
Titans of the DC Universe collide things
get ugly
mostly for Batman Diana beats him into
submission and stands with a foot on his
head if that isn't the ultimate symbol
of Batman getting owned we don't know
what is he escapes by invoking an
Amazonian ritual but it's a pretty close
call prometheus though he's a villain
you don't hear much about all now
farmacia Decius Prometheus is that man's
twisted mirror image and in an even more
literal way than Joker or two-face
Batman's family was gunned down by a
street thug but for me pieces herons
were criminals killed by the police
leading him to swear vengeance upon
those who attempt to bring justice to
the world like Batman he's a trained
fighter he's filthy rich and he's got a
sharp mind but despite sharing the same
name he has very little to do with the
Prometheus who makes an appearance in
the air of earth Prometheus masquerades
as the hero
petrol and walk straight into the
Justice League's watchtower with a
helmet that grants him the skills of the
30 greatest martial artists in the world
including Batman
he then beats the snot out of everyone
and his trouncing of the Justice League
only and when Catwoman whips him in the
nethers Tegan black fire the cult is one
of the darkest most brutal stories in
the Batman canon thanks to the vicious
Deacon black fire leader of a cult of
Gotham's homeless who have been
brainwashed into doing his murderous
bidding during his investigation into
the cult
Batman is captured by beacons forces and
sends a huge chunk of the tale being
tortured and kiss gently on the cheek
while high on psychotropic drugs it's
all an attempt to brainwash Batman into
fighting for blackfyres
underground army Batman's eventually
saved by Robin but not before being
reduced to a sobbing husk of his former
self and having his entire world view
shattered the best part Robin finally
gets Batman back for all those mean
friendly slaps to the face black fire
isn't even the only opponent to use
drugs to take down Batman either Swamp
Thing you might think that Swamp Thing
is a joke and if you've ever heard his
old cartoon game song you wouldn't be
wrong
[Music]
sad cartoons aside flossing isn't just
one of the most fascinating characters
in all the DC comics he's also one of
the most powerful in fact he's one
pretty much every fight he and Batman
have gotten into what Batman chases
Killer Croc into swamp things Wow the
big green guy takes out bats with a puff
of hallucinogenic pollen the most
memorable beatdown happened in Swamp
Thing number 53 when the must man's wife
is in police custody and he responds by
turning Gotham into a jungle when Batman
confronts him sloppy divides himself
into many swamp things and just beat the
snot out of Batman like it's a gang
initiation ritual poor Batman never had
a bat chance Deathstroke Slade Wilson is
one of the deadliest characters in any
comic book universe regardless of the
publisher he was the world greatest
killer even before the government
experimented on him making him even
deadlier one of his first fight after
getting his own comic book in the early
90s was with Batman at this point The
Dark Knight was already something of a
legend able to defeat any foe that
crossed his path so it was kind of a big
deal when Deathstroke and Batman threw
down in an old-school fistfight and
Deathstroke beat him into
unconsciousness by tossing him into a
bookshelf
the only reason Batman is alive today is
because Deathstroke spared him and they
ended up hanging around together for a
couple of issues afterwards Lady Shiva
the assassin known as Lady Shiva is one
of the greatest martial artists in the
world according to Batman himself when
she's not an ally of Batman she's
kicking his butt like in the pages of
Nightwing number zero when Shiva did
battle with both Batman and Dick Grayson
at the same time she downed Batman with
a poison tip shuriken then beat up dick
until she felt sorry for him and offered
to train him he declined but it was Lady
Shiva's influence that convinced Dick
Grayson to stop being Robin and become
his own man it was then that he decided
to become Nightwing not too many career
decisions come from watching someone
beat up your dad but hey comic books are
weird
Joker crushing Batman's psychologically
and pushing him to the edge of his own
sanity is the Joker's primary objective
and the list of Joker's offensive is
disturbing and endless but the only time
that the Joker has been able to
completely destroy Batman with
he still be awesome power of an
interdimensional imp using the abilities
of Superman antagonist mr. Mick see fit
lick Joker warps reality to kill that
man over and over until Superman makes
him realize that even though Joker is
all-powerful he just can't bear to let
go of Batman know you you are coming hey
Darkseid it's not surprising that
someone like Darkseid who's basically a
guide can take out a flesh-and-blood
mortal like Batman what was surprising
however was just how Darkseid did it
during the Final Crisis storyline it
looked like dark side simply fried
Batman to a crisp with his weird eye
lasers of course no one really ever
stays dead in comic books for long as it
happened Darkseid replaced that man's
body with a dead clone fooling Superman
and most of his super friends and sent
the real Batman traveling uncontrollably
through time why would he bother with
all of that because that man was turned
into a weapon whose fourth time travel
adventures threatened to undo all of
reality
eventually Batman with a lot of help
from the Justice League managed to
escape back to the present day without
destroying all of existence still the
important thing to keep in mind is that
he got his butt kicked and all it took
was a single glance holy spontaneous
combustion thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to